today I'd like to talk about the role of
air power in the course of World War two
World War two of course is the word we
use in America and it's equivalent to
the European or the British notion of a
Second World War there's a couple of
things to remember about air power
before we begin in earnest one is that
there was an enormous transformation
between its inaugural appearance in 1914
in World War one when pilots and
biplanes shot revolvers at each other in
less than 30 years about 25 years 24
years at the outbreak in September 1st
of 1939 in World War two we had mono
planes and the speeds had increased from
a hundred miles an hour to nearly 300
and people were firing about seven to
eight hundred shots per minute on
machine guns sometimes right through the
propeller sometimes on the wings and
they were carrying bomb loads in the
case of fighter bombers of five hundred
to a thousand pounds and bombers even
far greater so there was a miraculous
transformation in the role of air power
and that created theorists or prophets
Air prophets or architects of air power
so to speak in the European countries
and in the United States as well Billy
Mitchell duet weaver in germany and they
were so enthralled by this new weapon
that they made it a series of astounding
predictions and so much that Prime
Minister Stanley Baldwin in the late
1930s said in despair that the bomber
will always get through and it was
almost as if assets at sea navies and
assets on the ground infantry were going
to be secondary or even irrelevant the
war would take place up in the air the
problem with that is nobody lives up in
the air nobody eats in the air nobody
really can fly we don't have wings so
what you're doing is transferring label
labor and capital from the ground up
into the air and there has to be a
purpose for that and the purpose had to
be either air superiority or air
supremacy and by that I mean your Air
Forces had to beat the other persons
airforces for the prime reason that they
could then direct their assets to where
things really mattered on the ground
taking cities or territory or killing
people are capturing them on the ground
if you couldn't do that and you only
achieved air parity then both sides were
sort of wasting their time and in our
irrelevant theater so the purpose was to
build more planes and better planes and
train better pilots to destroy the
enemy's heirs assets or at least weaken
them so you had air superiority and then
the holy grail was air supremacy that
meant that you could put your assets up
in the air they could fly over the
enemy's territory destroy his cities or
his armies on the ground and they would
be invulnerable because you had
destroyed the enemy's ability to fight
back in the air and that was pretty much
the theory of airpower in World War two